always try to get a tape set I could
never get a good one to like submit to
late night or whatever and I finally get
this great set on the road it's Sunday
night last night so excited I go back
and go Bobby I finally I'm on the road
Bobby I finally got a tape and he goes
oh no you're gonna be so mad at me he
took my camera in the middle of my set
into the Green Room took down his pants
yeah I don't think I've ever forgiven
him but what an [ __ ] yeah what a dick
literally the other day
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George
I think the thing I gotta go to that dry
cleaner by Keith Phelps
new sport Sports
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
look better no turtlenecks make you look
skinnier you look more done yeah I look
more done yeah she came from my camera
commercial thing
will you try a commercial you look
amazing look at this and you always you
always look amazing
you look like a comedian oh
this is not Morgan Freeman
temporary
that's creepy
which would you believe me
oh my God
I don't know why people are doing the AI
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
so can your all your family members come
back
yeah oh yeah oh no
no
no
nobody will ever I got kind of Tipsy
after I drank one of these they're
strong and good
there's my slogan I like mine I like my
beer like I like my women
they're strong at why would somebody
drink beer without alcohol in it
seriously no it's because you have a
mouth fixation you know yeah oh or like
social anxiety cheers ching ching
everybody yeah we're not all this social
anxiety what I mean yeah I'm 100 years
old but how come what was it called when
we were growing up [ __ ] I don't know
losers stuck up
just like Wallflowers you know well I
don't think you had as much Social
Anxiety probably because you don't have
social media
do you guys what do you what do you do
like I put gum under all the tables and
chairs really no way I know no way I
can't do it what do you guys do you put
your finger in your ear finger in my ear
scratch my scalp
with my hair I fix my hair like this
too but is that is that no the scalp
thing it's nervous nervous tick tick
yeah
I just like touch my face a lot that's
also why I keep my nails really short
because when I have long nails I like
either scratch at my eye because you're
such a lesbian is that related to
another anxiety what no I mean
everything is I think it is right I
think some people don't even know
they're doing it until somebody says oh
man stop touching yourself no I'm not
touching myself oh my mom yells at me
about it all the time well I don't mean
if you ever did this but my dad would
cut my nails for me when I was a kid to
the point where they both like he would
get mad at me when they were alone is
that the equivalent of buying clothes
bigger so you grow into them yeah that
they take your nails all the way down to
the little Sun there the little Sun part
and then it's all bleeding and then it
hurts for two months and then finally
like I used to bite really aggressively
and then my mom said if you stop biting
your nails your boobs will grow and then
I stop biting my nails and nothing
happened how long they are my mom should
have said that yeah she's got a boob job
so yeah
do you really have yeah are those fake
tattoos yeah no way a lot of people
don't you held when you held them I
could tell because they felt heavy yeah
they know they're light they're like
34bs you know how do you decide what
size like like a rental car like what
did you need it for it's a handful like
what trips you're like you know I might
you know I I don't really know how many
Mexicans can I fit inside
I just wanted to look good in a bathing
suit you know I wanted enough to like
fill a bathing suit but and then what
about the Pasty white skin though like
the new skin where like it's no there
your whole skin Oh wait like your boobs
are awesome and then and then you have a
bikini on everybody like all right oh
you can spray tan it right yeah I don't
like spray tans you know you can tell
when people have like orange hands on
the inside and then they're like getting
the furniture dirty and I actually lost
color since I like moved to LA because I
like look the sun makes me like
depressed weirdly oh my God like it's
sunny every day and I'm like I need some
rain because I grew up on the East Coast
you're opposite the full show
I'm I love wait I love the Sun
yeah a thousand things that could go
wrong with somebody in a day yeah isn't
the Sun supposed to be what about what
about uh well because I'm like oh why am
I depressed well it's not the seasons so
it must be me you know what I mean you
just need a little bit of change I think
the sun is depressing because like I
should be doing stuff but I don't want
to I want to go into by the way this is
the number one dictionary phrase of the
year do you know how every year they
pick one it's uh going full Goblin mode
full goblet hiding out yeah it's like
just being and not caring and saying no
to going out and being like in your
sweats full Goblin mode I would have
thought full Goblin would have been
something else who started doing that
which is so cool who's the first guy who
did this who did this I don't know Frank
Sinatra
the guy's like yeah like Rat Pack very I
had a guy that I used to work with in
Las Vegas and he was a juggler and he he
was just the worst uh Probably sounds
like [ __ ] and he would do so much better
than me and at the curtain call he would
look at me he'd go
stop
okay
I mean he did so much like racial
racially in terms of aggressive this I
did racially insensitive [ __ ] too but
mine were words not a toilet seat he
goes hey man what's happening like that
he did that yeah let's go burn his house
am I missing it who is this man
and then when I started to do Arsenio I
went back there to go to Vegas and then
I went to go see those guys and uh
uh uh when uh when I saw him I went he
goes hey man I saw you on TV and I went
you know you can just say hey you can
just say it was Carrot Top just saying I
don't know if this guy David ianachi I'm
really into like egging people's houses
these days so if you want to get egg his
house
kind of what it ruined like
a point to you you know what I mean you
know it would be really insulting like
if you see a family then they're like
just you know [ __ ] nerds and [ __ ] and
you you threw egg whites at their house
yeah like no yolks just the white just
the whites that should be that's a funny
like comedy special name no yolks
no but you know that really it's it
really [ __ ] up the paint of your car if
you like it yeah but you just throw it
out the window
I'm so nice I came home I came home one
night and the house come home every
night one night I came home and Little
League team was toilet paper in the
coach's house
and I saw it as I turned around a corner
and I saw
the assistant coach that had brought the
kids over in her car
to do the toilet papering was parked
right in front of my house so I went
inside got a bunch of toilet paper and I
papered the [ __ ] out of her card and I
left her a note rule number one never
leave the getaway vehicle on the tent
there you go and I went back inside the
house and waited for them to come out
waiting for them to come back to the car
and got a big laugh we tp'd our baseball
coach's house but you know how much we
disliked the head caca on the toilet
paper
like like almost like velcro darts uh
stick to the house oh so bad no I'm a
people pleaser I would never do that if
they landed right here yeah oh my God
like when you throw darts with without
needles and they don't land right they
just fall oh yeah toilet paper wow they
have to clean that up
with Amanda my co-host yeah um and what
is your name Amanda Montel Amanda yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah she is good the host
of that show recommended a mushroom
therapist for me and I was so excited
you take mushrooms and he like guides
you through it oh yeah and I was so
excited and then I talked to the guy two
hours and then I go so how much is it
and he goes it's five thousand dollars a
session and you have to do a minimum of
three sessions I was like what what so
then I was like I'm gonna marinate on it
just take shrooms and go to literally
though literally costs fourteen dollars
but what what's that therapy though what
is that it's about like releasing
sometimes as like people we kind of hold
on to things in our body and sometimes
mushrooms helps you really like
hallucinogenics
yeah the mushroom people they're they're
on they're on us but all all that thing
is like when they go and do what's that
called with the r word where you go into
like a tent and sweat it out oh no
that's uh I uh oh my God
Ayahuasca Ayahuasca Alaska which yeah
you just projectile vomit but it's good
it's fine and then micro dosing too
right people know micro does Micro
dosing all the time now I feel like
shrooms are like the new I love shrooms
okay I've never done you know when you
did the Laugh Factory you were really
funny oh thank
you quite a unique uh delivery style
thanks thanks for having me on that show
what's up what's the uniqueness like she
stands really straight and she has her
hand like this you know oh I do yeah I'm
just like confident hey guys your pets
are up here
that's the style George it's mine yeah I
love when my vagina looks long they're
like
yeah
but it doesn't work yeah
I could run it women want to make your
vagina look like better I never thought
of it
that's what I like it covers your gut
you know like yeah
I can't see it
you know what a fupa is Gil no what it's
a fat upper [ __ ]
what's the a though upper [ __ ]
quick she's cute
what
all right just let me do let me have my
moment how dare you thank you
Reader's Digest version Oh people would
say that let me give you the Reader's
Digest part of it which was like
condensed oh my gosh we read a bunch we
read a bunch of uh like what are the
what are those called when they're like
gedias what are they called like words
that kids say oh slangs
if Gill knows what they are yeah
quick power yeah how about this when
somebody goes like yeah it's MIDI midi
they say mid now okay okay sorry mid do
you know what mid means like me is that
right there by the fupa
no it means like you're average it's
like oh like do you like that guy no
he's mid and it's like no he's like an
average loser he's a B minus C plus
would you turn a loser I could work I
could work up to be in the mid no you're
better than me can a loser a guy can a
guy can that guy can that guy become
something one day I'm gonna say all the
ones that I've seen growing up they
[ __ ] still are losers I don't know
yeah I mean it depends on the person
really you know no I say once a bit
always amid you say mid for a lot that's
the insult of mid it's like if you're
calling someone mid you're like you're
never gonna be more than mid yeah it's
like two like I wouldn't actually call
someone who has potential mid you know
what I mean what's the word for that
potential
have you heard basic yeah okay so when
someone's basic it's like when it's like
a basic girl yeah it's just ordinary
yeah but chugi is like a specific type
of ordinary it's like those you know
those signs that are in people's houses
that are like live laugh love
yeah that's choogy
she's like white women who are like
basic but between 35 and 45.
I don't know where it came from I don't
know but I love it I love calling you
people too who would be chewy like let's
let's who's a who's like thinking about
a choogie celebrity Reese Witherspoon
she's like a choogie celeb you know
because she's like that like Drew
Barrymore no no no she's cool she's like
cool
oh I guess yeah I guess she's too old to
be chewy because it's like a younger
version of Reese Withers he's like
cheesy
oh wow but in a good way kind of is all
those words I'm sorry are they in
stand-up stand up like if you went to an
audience and they would know what that
is oh wow it's like that yeah sometimes
I feel like people it goes through
people like and they're like what are
you saying but yeah I would I would say
like sorry I'm like if I went on stage
and was like doing crowd work or
something and I was like oh she's chewy
everyone would know oh yeah I'd never go
with my Mexican friends
let me think of the word in Spanish it
would probably be like
I don't know what it is in Portuguese
they say Matthew in uh in Texas and
Mexico is like yeah I would say the mid
they would say because I would always
say that
uh some people are full-on and Latinos
are Medio and they go man dude I was
full on
last night and then Mexico says like
he's half yeah exactly or half of it
yeah
but I think I think that when you're
older like us like there's no going back
like it's too far to go back to be they
don't understand the words no there's
only like a few that's the it's also
like as like younger like I'm like 27
which is like she's so old young I guess
but like there's like 23 year olds who
are like popping off quicker and faster
than me and like even they have like
language that I don't understand and as
that is happening now to me I'm like I
don't [ __ ] care like every generation
has like their own thing and it's like
it's just cool to like come up and like
make older people feel old but it's like
everyone [ __ ] gets old who [ __ ]
cares I love that their idea is to make
old people feel old yeah because they
don't have anything like money or power
so they're like all I have is my youth
there's a lot of that nowadays there's a
generation of like just like he's old or
like there's a lot of like I remember
when I was young I loved like older
people I respected them I looked up to
them podcast turns into like people
don't people don't respect the elders no
they don't I don't think they don't
especially in comedy yeah you know these
young house dude I'm like come to my
show they don't even sit through my set
I'm like what the [ __ ] whoa it's a
different hierarchy now people literally
will like pop off on Tick Tock and then
like immediately expect to like get
booked on shows because you know there's
shows in La that have been going on for
10 years that like people want to get on
it's like an honor to get on a good show
and people will have like what are those
shows well you know I was thinking maybe
like bathtub comedy at Virgil is like a
good one oh yeah
um
Christian
yeah hot tub's been going on for a long
time that's an excellent show hot tub
yeah I mean for me Mike falzone's like
surrounded he's been doing this like
crowd work oh I just saw I just wrote
like wrote them I was like I'm gonna do
this hard work only yeah 10 minutes of
just and everybody sits on this stage
and makes fun of you too yeah like you
have to sit like they it's in the Improv
in like the lab and they turn all the
chairs to be circled around the middle
and then you're surrounded by the
audience and you just have to do crowd
work but it's like a really fun it's an
also like there's a lot of that's the
thing he's like a club guy so he did
like you know what I mean but it's up to
improv yeah but that's an old show at
the Improv I feel like that it's not old
no yeah no you're right he's not who
started that I kind of how does somebody
Mike falzone he's really funny comedian
how does somebody start that like a show
a show idea no like that like like the
idea of you know we we go we don't want
to be heckled and then yeah we have a
show where you do 10 minutes of just
talking to the crowd I mean you know
what is it going to get to the point
where there's no jokes to be made
anymore that are like original yeah you
know what I mean have we gotten into
that already yeah we're getting there I
think I think we are too yeah yeah
because where if you go up there and
you're just doing an act and people see
it's an act they they're just they don't
care they want to know you they want to
know you I know lately I've been
starting all my sets with like at least
two minutes of crowd work because if not
like people clock out yeah yeah and you
want to make them they want to feel like
they're special so like you gotta like
point out a couple people in the
audience and then ease into your
material not me I like to treat them
like [ __ ] yeah yeah that's my thing yeah
my stand-up is mostly crowd work that
when I'm enjoying it yes you know what I
mean like jokes just feel good and
there's nothing prepared right no no I
have go-to's like I have little go-to's
like if I see a group of bros I'm always
like you guys are gonna kill a stripper
tonight huh you guys are gonna go and
then whatever happens I just saw the
most brilliant show called Nate have you
guys heard about this it's this woman
who does she dresses
he looks like she dresses like a guy so
she's topless the whole time with her
tits out it's on Netflix she made a
special of it and basically the whole
thing is a one-man show one man she's a
woman and she plays all the characters
and she like interacts with the audience
and the audience becomes characters on
the show she's like Luke Luke where are
you and like everyone's quiet like and
then finally someone's like yeah and
she's like Lou come here and then she
does like improv with these people it's
brilliant and she it's like very sexual
too so it's really good Natalie it's
called Nate I'll show you guys that's
some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] there too like
yeah these are out the whole time I just
was so jealous because I've been wanting
to be naked on stage I do feel like it's
just it is her titties are out the whole
look the whole time
she dresses like a dude she's British no
oh
it's it was one of the most brilliant
things I've ever seen see she just and
then she there's a shower scene where
she's like totally naked showering I
feel like that's like alt comedy though
it was so good I'm so jealous of it
because like one sheep both of the shows
are sold out it's like what's that like
and um and then also just the freedom of
like getting to play a character and
like it's I feel like there's this
crossover now between stand-up and
theater that you're seeing a lot in like
the alt comedy scene and it's like
people who like
don't want to do jokes and they want to
like do this like alt character thing on
stage and I'm like for sure that's cool
but like sometimes if I go to an ALT
show and I just want to do like my jokes
the audience is like not there for it
and I'm like dude I've been working on
these jokes for years they're not into
it like and they do well at a club but
then that's why I don't know I was just
in New York for a month and like the New
York comedies I feel like it seems so
much better though oh it's so hard there
I feel like I think it's hard I think
it's always been hard but how does
somebody come up with that I think she
started it as like a small one-woman
show kind of a thing where she was
playing with ideas and then she came up
with this character that was like super
funny and like getting a lot of
like that's super fun and goes freeing
oh you should watch it has anybody hate
it
I'm jealous of it did anybody has
anybody else done it I mean it's her
idea right is she the only one doing it
no that's so similar there's another
girl Courtney peruso who does this like
incredible show where she's like it's
like a clown kind of show but yeah it's
clowning so many people do it there's
this guy named Zach Zucker who runs this
show called stamptown and it's like a
three-hour show and it's a mix of like
stand-up comedians clowns and sketch I
like this I want to be a part of this
and yeah I started with clowning oh you
should I mean Zach is like the I don't
want to say this on the record because
his ego would like blow up but he is
like clown he's like doing the clowning
I love it what's clowning it's just
physicality and like it's like making
people laugh without like without phys
like with just being physical no jokes
no words just it's going so an example
of it is like I went to the show the
other day and this girl was dressed as
like this poor like
1950s like woman and she had like fake
blood all over her and she was carrying
a fake baby and so funny so far audience
being like do
there she just like took it to like this
extreme and like interacted with the
audience where like she got like half
again also half naked on the stage and
was like I just want to be naked on
stage how do I do that in common how is
that huh
I'm sorry you know before coming on the
show you know I'd pay to go see also we
can see I feel like we're talking like
very fast no I I pay to go see Comedians
and still today there's nothing that I
love more than watching comedy
but that is more like yeah
no I want to see comedians I want to go
see George make me laugh yeah and I can
remember don't throw me in there I can
remember the first comedian I ever paid
to go see was Dom Herrera who was yeah I
was on here yeah and I've seen paid
several that when I go to a comedy show
when I go to the laugh factors I want to
see people that are going to make me
laugh I don't want to wait in suspense
or when's the next last joke coming in I
guess there's a I don't know it's
changed so much since the last time you
guys were in here [ __ ] I didn't know any
of this oh she did this thing on the
show Nate where she would go to
different audience members and go may I
and then she would just grab their tits
and then she came up to a guy and she
was like may I and then she like grabbed
his dick it was so funny just she had an
audience on the palm of her hand the
entire it was just so fascinating to see
yeah how she had that I think that's
where like the line is drawn of like
Club comedy and like all like Theater
comedy I don't think one is writer one
is wrong but I do think that like
it's good to have those spaces like
clubs where like you can go in and just
like do jokes because like yeah even for
me I've started to perform to like
podcast audiences and I like love the
fans of my podcast but they're not
people who normally go to clubs right so
they are there yeah
I'm just kidding are they nervous listen
to my podcasts
they are they are nerdy but in like a
cool way and I love them but like I was
talking about it with a friend and he
was like you want to practice your jokes
in front of a comedy audience because
you'll know what actually works and what
doesn't they're not just like laughing
right that's true yep that's true like
you want to Workshop your [ __ ] at a club
we're shopping in New York and then you
come here and it's so much easier people
are fancy people are fans of Comedy
people who go to clubs are fans of
comedy and they know like you were
saying they're there for like like a
premise tag punch line and like that's
the art of like stand-up comedy but then
but then you know that even makes like
UCB or the grounding seem dated like
like that it stuck yeah in a sense
because they've been doing the same
thing which was different than stand up
and the things that we do and that was
the two things that are different but
Nate and all the stuff you guys have
been talking about is way outside risky
of those two things you know it's risky
because it could really offend people I
mean she did some crazy [ __ ] like and
it's the Elysian theater is like a place
that's been really open like and they're
trying to help people grow who want to
do risky [ __ ] that's not like that
hasn't been done you know like yeah I
was gonna try and do a show there but
they were like we're not taking any more
stand-up shows they're only doing like
all comedy I kind of want to do a weird
show I I drove by there once I didn't
know that was there and I drove by there
and I thought wow what a nice you've
been inside a nice theater that's where
the lady was the baby fake baby
wow I like I like how comedy's growing
because I felt really like suppressing
oh I love like male style comedy I grew
up I started a comedy store you know and
now I'm like finally I do music stuff
like I think it's starting so important
to like have all those Avenues and I
don't think one threatens another you
know they can all coexist you know but
you're gonna have to have to be going in
that direction anyways because it's not
something that you're gonna sit around
and become somebody who wants to go on
stage with your top off or yeah somebody
that's going to do completely all improv
yeah just like think about it and
there's not been a stand-up that's been
naked yet yeah there is in the United
Kingdom I went to Fringe Fest right oh
Fringe Fest as a whole which is like
Edinburgh Fringe Fest it's a Comedy
Festival in the UK
um and it's a month long you perform
every single night and they have a lot
of alt comments and you have to rent
your own space and you have for 28
nights and you have to bark and you have
to like sell tickets and you have to
rent the space it's a lot of work but so
much work it's exhausting it took like
an emotional toll on me and no sun
no I was so sad when I was there too
much it was too too much no sun that's a
lot to that's a 24-hour [ __ ] foreign
you know who's at the festival is
performing at different hours of the day
you can only hang out with your friends
between the hours of like midnight and 4
a.m so you're up until 4am every night
and then you get up the next day then
you're prepping for your show and then
you're barking barely get through a
weekend wow I can barely 25 shows I'm so
tired no I've never done that Festival
but I did it almost every weekend yeah I
buy like I have one weekend left this
this year and I'm exhausted by it
already I haven't started it I'm like oh
five hours worth of being on stage yeah
yeah that's that's insane yeah would you
ever try stand up he wants to I I might
try one these days I feel like once you
do it and you live you know what I mean
like you realize that it won't kill you
you're oh I'm not afraid of it killing
me I I just would like to I crowds don't
don't bother you know I think you should
speak in public doesn't bother I think
you should put a turtleneck on and then
stick your P the head of your pizza
the two turtlenecks
I do feel like the turtleneck would be
good for you or like a suit you know
like you have the voice of a suit no I
think you should do just do a turtleneck
that matches the pants one color
I just like seeing something different I
mean I was on the road with Bobby Lee
for years and it was so like I loved
watching he had all the same jokes but
he would do this different physical
thing that involved an audience member
every time so it's different because it
was yeah you never know what's going to
happen right when you involve the
audience and I don't know something
exciting about it it's exciting to me
because you don't know what's going to
happen yeah you don't know I'm at this
place where like I I'm starting to like
love crowd work a lot more but because a
lot of the podcast fans come out to the
show and I feel this like really
grateful relationship to them like
they're the reason I've been able to
like go independent as a comedian I
don't want to like attack them like go
independent I left my family yeah but
but I don't want to attack them but the
whole point of crowd work is like to
attack and what do they what do they
expect to see you do your jokes and all
that stuff or yeah I don't know
you shouldn't think about their
expectations I know I think I just like
think too much about like I'm so
thoughtful about other people 's
feelings
I came out of my mom's butthole instead
of her vagina
[Applause]
thank you that's hilarious
I think that you got to stop doing that
I know and when I do attack them the
times I do like they take it no but I
don't think it's attack I don't think
it's I don't think that's the right word
because then it's like I think people
can feel attacked but I think it's about
like in making them part of the show and
I think that's what feels like an attack
like right because comedy is like taking
the usual making it a little off yeah
yeah that's what makes people laugh
because laughing is not necessarily
Happiness by the way it's like a
discomfort no I think it's an it's an
organic react it's an impulsive like
reaction that's what I love about comedy
is like if I laugh like you say
something funny there I couldn't control
it like I just laughed yeah you don't
think of it yeah but also you know Gary
Shanley would say that if they moaned or
if they were like turned on you or if
they laughed in a plus break it was a
reaction and silence was the [ __ ] that
you didn't want but if you could make
the whole world go oh no visceral I mean
that's that's yeah that's what I get
whenever I do my um Colombian cocaine
joke thing it's like like whenever I
meet someone and I I tell them I'm from
Colombia they're like oh cocaine like
Pablo Escobar you know that guy and I'm
like I don't do that to like white guys
you know I don't go up to a white guy
from Colorado and say oh call a mine oh
yeah
I do sometimes I do sometimes the
audience is like hahaha and sometimes
they're like oh and I'm like that one
was but what a great present you get a
new and then yeah have you ever have you
ever like pulled a punch like not not
done it because you thought oh no these
[ __ ] are gonna yeah sometimes I
skip that part and I just go to my other
one which is like I don't go up to white
families and say Fox News you know I
like that that's good yeah [ __ ] them
don't think about them yeah and what is
the road lead you think like in the what
what are you what are you guys aspire to
be like um oh yeah yeah that's that's
that's what what about us it come I
would let you know we talked about this
my dream is to develop a sitcom that's
what I've been trying to do for 15 years
I think you know Brazilian in Virginia
you know I grew up in Virginia too no I
moved to America Virginia when I was
seven stop what part Nova you know
Charlottesville I also went to UV
Fairfax is cool stop yeah wait a minute
the name of the show is America Virginia
I I was going to call it virginias for
lovers oh that's good too I lived in
America Virginia that's what you're
saying
Virginia America Virginia America so you
guys didn't know that you guys were well
I don't know if you knew but I knew
because of yours I didn't know I also
have a joke that's like yeah I moved
people don't believe me that I'm Latina
I moved to America when I was seven ESL
English as a second language and then
I'm like apparently I nailed it yeah
it's true people oh no people are like
no you're not yeah okay and both of you
are right yeah she was seven I was 12
when I'm 11. yeah I moved my sister was
your age yeah my sister was nine so oh
my God we gotta write it I think there's
a yeah just I think people just didn't
know what we were I think that's the
problem yeah and my parents literally
own like a wholesale flower business so
Everyone likes on the floor
no shut up the front door
that's so my mom's a florist
do your parents get flowers from
Denise's wholesale Express
come on you guys you should see my neck
it's really wrinkly you do look a little
bit you look what right
do I look old no you're here
I look exactly the same no I just have
eyeliner thick thick it's the only
virginal thing left on my body it looks
great thank you so much I've never dyed
it it does you know are we right are we
writing that you know NBC uh is looking
for
companions so they want Friday night to
be two-hour block of of shows so that
they so they match the ones yeah yeah
yeah because they did you know what we
see the Hispanic thing a lot but there
really is not anything besides the
Mexican like you know what I mean like
it's only because Mexicans are primarily
in Los Angeles right right adjacent to
the internet easier to make fun of
Mexican people because there's like the
stereotypes I mean when I was a kid
people like were like oh you're Mexican
you're Mexican I'm like
I mean I'd be cool being Mexican but
like I'm Colombian dude yeah people did
not know there are different Latinos no
those are people that don't know what
that is and um the idea even even in all
shows that were where characters were
Jewish of a censor like Bob Newhart had
different quirky kind of people that's
really what it is yeah it's not
ethnicity as much as it is the
quirkiness I don't know if you feel this
but I go to Colombia like often but it's
this weird like in between where like my
cousins are like ah it is gringa like
you're a gringa gringa and then my
friends in America like make fun of me
for like being Colombian so it's like
we're kind of in the crazy I relate more
to the term Latino than I do like
anything else because it's like this
like mesh of like Latinos in America you
know what I mean like we all have the
same experience of like being immigrants
but like and going back to our home
countries and our cousins being like
[ __ ] losers you know what I mean yeah
because they're jealous right it's
difficult watching you speak right now
you know and you because you look I
don't know why you you you look born
raised American and then you say Latina
you don't say Latina nobody say Latina
but don't you you think she look you
look I feel like you look Argentinian or
like you look like I want to be argue
she looks like she was born and raised
in Virginia we're all we're like raised
we're racist about our own race if it's
not our specific yeah but the rest yeah
no it's true I mean
that's something like my whole like but
some people are like yeah you do look
Latina and if I go back to like if you
go to Columbia I do look like most
Colombian girls yeah same I look really
pretty but when I'm in Brazil but where
does the idea like you know when I was
growing up uh when anybody was your
guy's age they were afraid to make a
decision which a lot of the kids or
young people still do but where do you
guys get
the commitment or the drive to say I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do stand up I'm gonna
do this and I'm not gonna get a job I'm
not gonna try to do that this is what
I'm gonna I'm gonna stick with that I
mean that's always I always wanted to I
mean really yeah I got my masters in
public policy I thought I wanted to do
it
yeah that's another thing I like went to
UVA to like go to law school and then I
got my Master's Degree and then I moved
to LA for like a regular job at a
non-profit and then I started doing
stand-up because I had no friends and I
love comedians that's so funny out of
all the people that are good friends you
went for God I know
literally like now all my friends are
comedians which is like so you good and
bad friends yeah yeah
and then like you know now we're here
and you fell into it are they reliable
good for you the comics are the worst
what no I said now we're friends
small hands your hands feel tinier too
remember the two chickens I used to
drive around the Zach for the Zach you
farm chicken farms chasing them your
little fists again close it that's the
way the chicken hand looks like
but to answer your questions
oh
I don't know
well I was just to answer your question
is that like I didn't really like just
push like I was I mean I don't know you
probably felt this but I've been
as like my career has grown I keep
feeling like regret for not having
started sooner I'm like oh [ __ ] I should
have started sooner I should start
sooner and I'm like now I'm like
whatever no don't hurt yourself how old
are you 27. there's no [ __ ] how do
you even think that yeah people that
start when they're young it's like well
because I know Comics who like didn't
even like go to college so they started
stand up when they were 17 and like by
the time they're like 27 they've been
doing it for 10 years you know and like
with stand up yeah but most likely
they're [ __ ] awful yeah but you don't
know yourself when you first started I
think I started when I was 18. I was
[ __ ] awful for 10 years yeah but then
but then you were comfortable on stage
and you can tell you know and like it's
been me pushing and pushing and pushing
to be because I know I'm funny but I
just want to be myself on stage I want
to get to the point where like I don't
give a [ __ ] and I can just be myself and
that takes time yeah it does it just
takes time I wore myself on stage than I
am off stage because I have this new
therapist he's like a cholo it's funny
he's like you're depressed homie um
and he's like uh he's like on stage
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
you're get off and you're like please
I'm sorry yes it's so weird like I'm a
very like I'm a total pushover wow and
I'm starting to learn how to be like
[ __ ] off like you know to be my stage or
something is your boyfriend an actor no
hell no what does he do he's in finance
oh yeah he is good he's hot cash that is
yeah
no no no he's a normal person with a
normal Soul yeah that's nice but I did
data comment for eight years so I want
to date a normal person yeah but yeah I
don't know I don't have time for it but
a normal like what like a no it's like a
dentist no this [ __ ] are all
depressed and [ __ ] I did hear that yeah
yeah my dentist the other day he goes uh
[ __ ] the guy one you see won two
million dollars or two billion dollars
that whatever the pot was and I go if
you want it would you ever ever do
Dentistry again he's like I would never
look at a tooth again and I was like
wait so you don't love it why do
dentists hate their job so much we all
hit our jobs nobody likes to work why is
that when I was 13 I was going to
Denison and I went in there I said
where's Dr Rose and everybody was like
oh and uh he committed suicide
oh
[Laughter]
dude they're [ __ ] perfect yeah
frazzled in perfect smile I have so much
[ __ ] to do tomorrow I'm going to the
dentist tomorrow shout out to doctor
dude I never went to the dentist as a
kid other than when we went back to
Columbia because that shit's so
expensive in America it's so expensive
are we supposed to find you though
like by your dental records
I don't think I went to the dentist
until I was in the Army yeah I never
went to a dentist because they're
supposed to [ __ ] last you that's
right horrible teeth do you guys don't
you have like I've had like I never had
anything those are they're pretty good
that's pretty good over 40 cavities
oh I've had cavities root canals
everything's fake
yeah
cavities I've had so many cavities you
go to sleep without brushing your teeth
and all that no in Brazil you grow up
with the out fluoride I remember there
was a commercial that was like how many
times you brush your teeth and this kid
was being like interrogated I mean it's
like twice a day and he's like what are
you an American and then it's like make
sure to brush your teeth four times a
day no and I think more importantly like
after every month that's a great
commercial by the way yeah I love that
what are you an American and I didn't
have I didn't have cavities or any you
know I had root canal problems when I
went in the Army but I didn't have major
dinner I took care of your teeth yes it
has nothing to do with it also and
genetics genetics genetics that it has
to be genetic if that's involved because
my parents had good teeth as well yeah I
come from a long lineage of homeless
teeth I guess because yeah but you guys
have perfect teeth yeah but it's only on
the it's like my emotions I was just
gonna say it looks good on the outside
but everything's [ __ ] up on the inside
oh I love that like a little swan on the
top it's like and then under it's like
yeah but I don't think you could date
somebody normal I don't think I don't I
don't think I
perpendicular to the industry right like
somebody who's a producer maybe yeah I
mean or like somebody who not a writer
like nothing like an EP executive yeah
like a showrunner show runner that's a
good one anything that's in conflict is
going to be a problem I can tell I'm
very jealous one headshot per
relationship and you're jealous too yeah
I'm Latina dude no you're gonna until
you get older you don't care anymore I'm
like I don't care it's like whoever's
titties you want to suck well I feel
like
are you guys in an open relationship
but I do he does allow me like because
I'm pan and I like so you're a pan
that's why you don't get jealous yeah oh
yeah
pansexual means that I'll let gopher
whatever like whatever potty part you've
got well I guess I'm pansexual too but
I'm sorry I thought you meant Paulie oh
no no no no no I'm not poly but you know
I I used to be a lot more jealous so
pansexual is like bisexual but you're
okay with like any gender or non-binary
person and polyamorous is when you date
multiple people at the same time and
there's another one ready there it is
there's another one called e m ethical
non-monogamous oh yeah so people are
like in relationships but they're open
ethically so that you like have to
communicate and go like hey this is my
primary person we don't wear a condom
and then you [ __ ] strangers in the side
yeah and everyone knows about it and
it's cool where was all this [ __ ] when I
was younger there was just not names for
it it was used
that's how far we go back yeah it was
like for women it was like for the
streets and for men it was like okay a
show called putas is a good title
where you let women become [ __ ] for a
week and follow them around become
because like women that are like maybe
Housewives but they want oh like open up
their relationship oh that's a good one
like remember true life on MTV it was
the best day yeah they did and it was
like they would just follow people and
they're like I'm an alcoholic they were
like many series documentaries or
whatever they should do what about a
senior citizen that goes to moves into a
senior citizen living where it's not
confined you can go and come and she
turns into the senior citizen puta dude
all the old guys that's really funny
because apparently like senior citizen
homes have like the highest STDs
the one down down in uh Leisure World
Leisure World had a big big deal because
he's like this place I used to go pills
everybody was doing it now and there
were so many wait like Viagra Viagra
yeah and they were having it was in the
news probably about 10 years ago
for women
that's true I
wasn't like very interested in and then
he bought me Bad Bunny tickets and I was
like stop
beautiful stop
gave you that what does it say it's
death row I gotta take a picture of this
with the shirt it looks so good yeah the
shirt's good can I ask you on here would
you have to give up for that oh my life
but not yet
snatch it off man oh yeah remember I
think it's Suge Knights but he's not
gonna need it
that's chunky is it heavy I did his
movie underdogs oh yeah and I said uh
hey I'll take my fee in a in a death row
chain because he he said he bought Death
Row Records so then his assistant said
uh hang on for hang on to that for a
second you might be surprised I'm
jealous I want to hang out with him and
smoke weed with him so you said you're
gonna bring me cool we gotta go smoke we
gotta do that yeah
um I'll smoke what were you gonna say oh
Bad Bunny tickets yeah I was just saying
that like I never really thought I was
like the kind of girl who would like be
into like you know gifts or things like
that do you feel did you feel obviously
no no definitely not I would never I
have very strong boundaries I like if I
don't feel comfortable doing something I
don't want to do something I don't
[ __ ] do it that's what like no I'm
not gonna well girls are different now
you guys are different but like with my
friend it was like out he like bought me
Bad Bunny tickets or got me them like
just to be kind and I was like oh my God
that's the hottest thing everyone has
ever done for me like I have language
It's My love language yeah your nipples
get hard or do your ears get hotter
[Music]
as a pansexual I feel like it's more my
brain me too that thing goes off in my
brain same me so I'm like holy
personality but it doesn't make you
sexual it turns you on inside yeah yeah
in your head yeah
yeah like your fire on your
um yeah
I have a P.O box for anyone listening
well for the for the podcast yeah yeah
what do you want to send you
um tickets to Bad Bunny uh new couch you
know the modular couches oh that's cool
I want people to call me and go I'm
proud of you yeah you do yeah I like I
need validation that's what up thank you
so much I'm proud of you thank you guys
so much you know what it is you know
what it is guys in comedy they release
their specials but they have the
camaraderie of the whole Community right
other guys it's a late night spot when a
guy gets a late night spot they like
watch it at the club too yeah women
don't do that well they still don't come
out yeah when a girl gets a late night
Spa it's like you're alone at home it's
true that we don't but you know what
women don't show up like my followers
okay 80 men like 20 women all my stuff
is Four Women yet they refuse to like it
like it what is that yeah
repetitive Okay so there's an underlying
competitiveness in women I also think
it's just like Bridging the Gap still is
like more men go to clubs like Club
comedy is very male oriented just
because of the scene oh no it's always
been it yeah you don't want to be you
don't want to go out and get hit on on
the whole night but what my friend has
been noticing I have a friend who like
has gone by on Tick Tock and is like
using that to tour the country like on
his own and he's noticed ticket sales
all the names are under the woman and
they buy two tickets the women are the
ones buying tickets for them and their
boyfriend that's cool yeah tick tock's
changed everything for me it has on the
road like my numbers online has changed
everything for me for my numbers on the
road and how do you how do you approach
Tick Tock then I I pay someone who runs
it for me I'm not gonna lie in the
beginning I was just too overwhelming so
he gets like the Hashtags with time to
do it we've got videos and stuff like
that but I interact like I'll go and you
know some people don't understand like
the normal the the the normal or the
person that's that out there is that
most people Don don't do their own
social media oh yeah yeah I just started
I mean I post my own stuff but I just
started paying someone to like cut my
clips for me because I was like because
it's emotionally draining to like watch
your own set because you have to let's
say like one joke bombs you have to like
watch that to like get to that okay
watching my own self do you know it's
like painful I mean I think it makes you
a better comic and I still I I prefer to
I listen to my my sets but I can't
[ __ ] watch them I know I look so ugly
my lips yeah I started too
I'm starting to I bought a new backpack
that's like a tiny backpack and it has
like a little pocket for my nice camera
[ __ ] take it to every show now
because I used to be paranoid that when
I filmed my sets I would have a bad set
and now I'm like well if I film every
single set also sometimes Clips do well
when they didn't do well in person you
never know like what hits online right
like it might be a quiet moment there's
no not even laughs and I have it'll have
like four million views and you would do
that used to go early and he had a
tripod like that and he would stand in
the back of the room and he would you
know adjust it and and then put it into
the sound system like that and he's the
only one doing it he goes dude once I
just record it through the system no no
this is better you don't want to see
myself but if I got off stage they took
his [ __ ] camera
the room wasn't all the way full so
everybody was ahead and nobody was that
bad nobody was watching so we was on
stage that's already walked through this
wait someone stole his camera took off
that's so [ __ ] up so when he got up he
went to go looking like so excited he
was all excited and [ __ ] just the
tripod was there
always try to get a tape set I could
never get a good one to like submit to
late night or whatever and I finally get
this great set on the road it's Sunday
night last night I'm so excited I go
back and go Bobby I finally I'm on the
road Bobby I finally got a tape and he
goes oh no you're gonna be so mad at me
he took my camera in the middle of my
set into the Green Room took down his
pants
yeah I don't think I've ever forgiven
him but what an [ __ ] yeah what a dick
literally the other day somebody was
filming a set and he was just [ __ ]
with the camera like Bobby what is wrong
with he has a problem that's not funny
yeah I would sue him now that I have a
lawyer
hi what hi hi I need to sue a comic yeah
his what are the terms what TV guys have
you guys done
um or what TV would you do oh I haven't
done any TV if you want to help out with
that we don't have enough time what do
you want to do though I want to do in
terms of stand up I'd want a late night
set I think what are the top three late
night sets well Kimmel doesn't do stand
up anymore he stopped so I think Jim and
then Jimmy Fallon just started so I
think I would do Jimmy Fallon or Corden
because Corden what I've noticed is he
um Mike's the audience so the set
actually sounds really good so like
isn't he going away though I understand
Courtney was on his way back yeah yeah
I don't think they have stand up they
don't have stand up but Trevor I was
leaving too um I want to host the Late
Night show that's my that's a dream I
really want to be the first female comic
to host late night what happened to the
girl that was doing NBC the Indian girl
oh uh Lily saw it yeah I don't think she
had a lot of experience with doing like
stand up and she was a YouTuber yeah oh
it's over yeah it's over yeah she's
really sweet girl how long did it go uh
two seasons I think two seasons I also
think it's hard to do was it for a
streaming service right um no it was uh
it was NBC but it was peacock so it was
like the late night maybe that's got
some [ __ ] yeah hey that's my dream
peacock oh wait I didn't post this but
by the way I got picked up
congratulations
when I was in New York another winner
pictures billboards
no I think she's you know she's all
right wait I want to show you wait who
cried
my daughter oh I know I follow her
I was telling Jimmy Kimmel last night
it's almost like I
I can't say no like I'm doing the
People's Choice Awards tonight
because they asked her and she goes I'll
do it and then
and then I I wouldn't
oh that the one that Drew a dick on me
no oh I did see that one but I didn't
take a picture let me see you did
oh that's so great the colors I we went
to a Raider again there's a guy this guy
named Doug and he and and he's you know
from San Francisco a well-to-do guy and
you know when you start drinking you
know everybody who grew up with money
wanted wants to make it seem like
they're down so you know he goes my mom
you know used to work two jobs and and
you know I'm not a like a like a uh what
they call trust fund baby and he's just
going on and off right we're looking at
him we're like and I said hey my mom had
to suck dicks to make ends meet
I go do you know whose dick she sucks
she goes no I went no
[Laughter]
did you see Dolly Parton telling that
joke the other day on Fallon no it says
this whole thing about this bear that
they they would feed Cokes to this Bear
right it was like an attraction and then
one [ __ ] like fed him gasoline and
the bear broke out and he's running
around and then you know he passes out
and then Fallon goes is he dead she goes
no he just ran out of gas
yeah it's really good she's funny she's
really good if you see her concert she
does a lot of stand-ups you ever hear
the one where they where the guy goes in
he has an alligator under his under his
arm and he puts it at the at the bar and
uh he goes down the other side of the
bar and he takes his pant dick out and
he takes a club and he hits a [ __ ]
alligator on the head bam and alligator
comes and blows them
automatic all right
does anybody want to try it I will but
don't hit me so hard
[Laughter]
wait so what does that have to do with
you like they don't when it's too like
you know but those are the kinds of
things I fall in love with I
romanticized old school comedy so much
Andrew Dice Clay yeah like Hawaii I used
to love Michael yeah I mean Andrew Dice
I'm thinking of it Michael T told us a
story went out to dinner with him they
were doing we were filming uh
I used to do this all the time when we
recorded here when I'm drinking
something I'm like
um
forget Michael T is telling us a story
when they were filming uh
anyways he he picked up he was filming
Forrest Gump they got done shooting they
were shooting in Georgia everybody's
leaving the set he says there was one
guy having trouble with his car it was
an extra
I felt sorry for the guys today I'm
going back into town you want to ride he
says yeah he goes he just about to get
through so I forgot something runs back
to his car grabs a bag gets back in the
car Michael D started driving and
Michael D's told me says yeah he says
you know the guy kept looking inside the
bag
and so I just said hey you must have
some awful important in that bag he says
yeah he says you don't mind me asking
what is it the guy looked at me said
none of your business [ __ ]
Michael says I slapped on the [ __ ]
brakes threw his ass out of the car he'd
have to bag in there and I [ __ ] took
wow man that whoa and then I asked him I
said in the back so what was in the bag
he looked at me and said none of your
business
that's a joke
I'll go authors yeah they're opening
again February 10th
Ice House oh they were closer they've
been closed this whole time
yeah I'm excited the first time I went
to the Ice House
I was still working during the day
and I left my job to go there and and
audition for one guy and I was in
Northridge Bob no this guy Dave McNary I
think he retired yeah and I left my day
job and I [ __ ] flew over there and
did like six minutes and went back and
he didn't laugh you know and then he
came back and he called me because he's
all kind of nervous he's like yeah I
think I'll give you a shot you know they
always sound like that too like they're
doing you a favor yeah they are yeah
that was at the time that was like 80.
boy did you interact with Mitzi do you
have any Mitzi stories yeah Mitzi told
me she was wearing too funny
this Paulie Shore's mom yeah I went in
there and uh they gave me the list they
gave me the light and then give them the
line they said I was I was you know
doing good they're trying to leave the
light on I'll turn it off so I did more
I go what you want me to do because keep
going and then went up there and then I
went back there to go meet you and
started and I said well how did I do and
she goes
rhyme and I'm like I'm from uh San
Fernando Valley from Mission Hills why
don't you work there the club's there
for a couple of years and then come back
and then like almost like they got you
by your [ __ ] callers [ __ ] they don't
clubs over there [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you may
work the clubs in Mission Hills for
[ __ ] until two years too yeah it'll
be like two years and then at Richard
Pryor's funeral uh David uh uh West
what's his name David West
the three dudes that were Richard Pryor
Paul Mooney and David Banks he passed
away I don't know him I'm writing
everyone thanks
and Mitzi is coming down the the aisle
there at the White Chapel at Forest Lawn
and she's about this big and she's got
all this hair and she's old and all in
black and just shuffling down the thing
and he sees her and he goes look he goes
look at this and it's Mitzi
and he waits for her to get past us and
he sticks his arm out and he grabs her
on the on the forearm like this and he
goes don't leave you'll be back
Wednesday
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
in the [ __ ] Chapel
oh my God and he said when I ran outside
of the back of the [ __ ] chapel and he
comes out he goes where'd you go I
[ __ ] was dying I mean I'd be laughing
yeah
Richard Pryor's funeral no but I have to
although I guess if it's one funeral
yeah
every comic that passes away it's
horrible but I have to admit like the
funeral's at The Comedy Store are the
hardest I laugh because it's like when
you when you have so much pain like that
release like laughter is released
I was also talking to like a friend of
mine another stand-up and he has a lot
of friends yeah
do you spend a lot of time alone or not
uh it's yeah I I you know what I could
not have done stand up if I had to be
around people
I do want to I currently have let's just
say I currently have roommates and uh
I'm trying to move out for sure I want
to be alone they have day jobs so I do
spend like all day alone at home but I
want them to not come back
dude they stopped supporting me like
they've stopped I've a lot of [ __ ] has
happened this year that has been great
and at first they were like congrats and
now they don't even like look at me when
they get home what do they do that have
real jobs they have yeah both of them
are sisters
yeah
the contention is right sure what shows
you guys want to be on I want to help
you guys get on really I wonder if I can
get you guys on show I want to be on
Hacks my favorites no no but a stand-up
show oh I would love to do like late
night Jimmy yeah
yeah
but like in terms of TV shows yours yeah
yours just put us on yours yeah but
people like twins
we can play sisters or like we should
have you guys aunts yeah or young girls
or you know what or we're bad or a bad
influence on your daughter and we start
to get her to do that yeah
and then we come in and we get her to do
all this bad stuff and at the end you
know you gotta do the sitcom thing she
goes Dad I'm sorry I should have
listened to you I should yeah I
shouldn't have hung up well I think it's
pretty good to have
cousins from like Brazil and Colombia
and we're like I can be from a different
place
went to school with and you know yeah
with that it's like that yeah and we
like
um we try and convince her to like open
her relationship up with her husband
right well that's good
we're like we're like yeah we're like
come on ethical non-monogamy everyone's
doing it
I think you guys should I think I should
consider writing a show oh well honestly
good luck I've tried so many I've
pitched so many shows well let's do it
together oh yeah she can actually write
so maybe you got them right uh do it
together do it together yeah do it
together yeah I also like honestly I
work better like in group me too like I
whenever I want to write I like text all
of my friends because I have so many
yeah no and I go to like I'm like let's
meet up at a coffee shop because like if
not I don't I need someone to hold me
accountable you know I'm like if you're
working I'm working but if I'm alone I'm
on Instagram you know I'm like
distracted What shows have you not done
that you want to do no we can get you
I'm just kidding yeah let me see what I
can get you on no what have you done
that you don't want to do he's done
everything
with Johnny Carson you did Carson I did
that and also you worked with Joan my
idol yes and
um way back to The Carol Burnett Show no
not [ __ ] remember
um but all all the all the main ones are
sunio and then Pat Sajak even you know
what I really do you ever do another
late night okay how about this dude I
gotta get over the idea of like
convincing mind like cheat on her up oh
yeah I think that's funny and especially
because he's like white we can be like
come on you gotta get a Latina
and then we go with all these cholos and
we get her hot I think it's pretty good
that's a good idea actually yeah that's
hilarious isn't everybody's parents
they're they're worse nightmares like
they're bringing some kids there to make
friends with these kids and they're bad
influence that's always the fear but
it's not even a bad influence they're
just out there having fun yeah to us to
be a bad influence yeah they're just
having fun yeah but maybe then she
Catches Us then you end up coming out
with us that's the plot twist just like
it's normally in like regular
relationships like the dad would be like
you could be related to L yeah oh yeah
yeah and he hasn't really had as much of
a storyline yeah not yet yeah he will
he's and the plot twist is that like
she's expecting you to take her side and
then like yeah you should be going out
more with girls like this well uh
there's a there's a there's a uh
thing where Stephen tobolowski the guy
the actor
okay yeah uh what would you say he's
done that Groundhog Day yeah Groundhog
Day and uh he plays uh the the queen you
know um what's his name
he plays the insurance salesman
groundhog day but also plays Matt's
father and he comes in he's like perfect
that's amazing he's so funny on
Californication oh you did oh yeah yeah
and supportive so we're trying to find
some dirty laundry on him you know and
then
um he doesn't have any and then Al and I
are smoking weed in the in the in the
van that we created that band and we
take pictures of we're gonna try to
frame them yeah we take pictures of of
Al does this
and I got the camera and I'm going open
it up be happy be happy and he's moving
his elbows different parts
yeah [ __ ] hilarious oh that's good
and he's like crawling too big walk
towards me walk towards me
this is also this one is like a butthole
yeah and this one's got like you know
you got a little hair too so like that
yeah like that one yeah except mine and
I just have like that mine is like this
do it again it is yeah yeah mine's like
I got a big old
I'm sorry
you're all so Brazilian so you have like
a Brazilian wax like there's no no no
I'm lasered oh right yeah you are yeah
the whole body
I like to invest I no I have a bush I'm
not like a child but yeah yeah
like Brazilian is like Brazilian wax is
like low-key pedophile Vibes because
it's like it looks like a baby you know
yeah but some people like that like I
like my I like my boyfriend wax his
butthole
so that's probably a good idea yeah I
like I just like it clean but but isn't
the hair there as a purpose almost like
a shield to catch it yeah to catch catch
germs and yeah
the guy was like my guy was like I want
he was like I want a girl to fax my butt
and I'm like you're not getting a girl
you're getting a gay guy that's what's
good that's what happens yeah you do the
best work yeah and when we went there
there was like the guy who played uh who
was that Superman show what was it
called uh Smallville Smallville the guy
from Smallville his head shot was on the
wall I was like see man in good hands
if they bleach your oil Smallville
that's what it's called have you been in
a Smallville yet like they do Pink
Cheeks at some point I think Pink Cheeks
you know because you know that's a good
one we're out there yeah we've got a lot
of living to do you know on that note I
have to pee I'll be right back all right
go ahead um wait but I do want to tell
you this I just went in for the reboot
for Frasier so if you want to put in a
good word
what part was that I went in for Olivia
One Time One series regulars first time
you went in or call back um I went in
for a one roll and then they brought me
in for a different series regular so but
it was all taped so I don't get to get
any gauge of how I want I think you'd be
good on the show I think right yeah yeah
yeah I was a series regular on a show
what show were you on it's called
Manhattan Love Story it was on ABC we
didn't even make it a whole season but
it was a good show I was part of it it's
tough isn't it it's really tough like I
don't think people understand like
especially right now because there's so
many questions yeah because you can do
comedy I can always be a comedian I can
be a better comedian always but the
thing is like my heart I want to act
like I really wanna so the soup was a
perfect thing because I got to be a
comic and then I also got to do sketches
and stuff like that right do the soup if
I yeah but I really want to host late
night I really want to host a late night
show and I really want to act again I
just want to you know commercials is
fine you can still get commercials but
you know when when I you know when I got
my first show years ago I had never even
gotten many auditions much less [ __ ]
book your own show with named after you
so all that stuff was all brand new to
me in the beginning and then you know
the ratings will come out I got picked
up and then you do like 120. nobody
thought we'd get back that's insane by
the way that never happens that's my
first show how I couldn't even get
auditions for TV yeah there's the other
year I know and then all of a sudden
you're in there and you're going there
for years and now you're starting to
be like that's your job and you know
you're coming back and then when you
leave
since you were inside I don't think you
realize how hard it is to get in because
you were in I was in for so long I had
office at Warner Brothers for 10 years
that's my dream driving up to Warner
Brothers you just drive on and hey and
you go in there and you change you go
there and you go home and it's just like
this [ __ ] amazing job and then when
it was over you know I did two years of
the of the talk show and then you think
you're out because I've been back to ABC
and CBS and that wait what show was your
talk show on again it was ABC TV or TBS
okay yeah and uh we're talking about
doing some stuff other more freedom
because all this stuff is like all brand
new again so yeah people are like oh
George yeah we should get you to do some
hours for it yeah I mean Backstreet Boys
are Back did you ever do another talk
show yeah
would you or you want to I would yeah I
would too it's like kind of like a
podcast so it's kind of like this yeah
and then you know there's so much
there's so many references that are that
are made of of the show like I was
watching uh Johnny Carson Ed McMahon
George wait let's all audition right now
to be George's sidekick
live commercials yeah hi uh hi I have
anxiety
wait that's my life but you know so let
me so so you know when they presented
this this idea like I think two years
ago a year ago you it's the furthest
thing from your mind that it could go
because there's so many buckets and
who's they like do you have a wrap like
yeah they pitch it and they see whether
you like it and then you know mine's
like I don't like this part of it and
you're in that and Chen had a show yeah
like [ __ ] you haven't even had a show
before yeah like [ __ ] because something
real yeah yeah and then you you start to
get closer and then they buy it and then
you go to the pilot and now you're like
this is gonna get picked up and then you
go and get the 13 and you do the 13 and
now you're like are you is it gonna no
is it gonna be nine more is it gonna be
yeah a whole a whole night but you know
for being a comedian like you know us
like you know you're in the clubs but
then going during the day and you're
rehearsing and then you're in that and
you go it's the [ __ ] it's the best
it's the best that's what I want because
like that's what I like Miss about even
though my day job wasn't in something
that I like wanted my dreams to be in I
love working with people like I want to
go in somewhere and like work with other
people and I feel like stand up alone
can be such a lonely so solitary I'm so
sick of it like if I don't have a friend
with me on the road it's really
difficult for me yeah it's really hard
and I'm like I'm gonna go do stuff 14
hours later I've been like watching yeah
and even though everyone feels bad
everyone is also prioritizing their own
career so as much as like you want to
work with other people and stand up
you're like our schedules don't line up
so it's like if you're on a show with
someone it's your job then you have to
you work and then the show ends and
nobody talks again and you're like were
we really friends but also but also all
I know right yeah okay but also so um
you know the show hadn't come on it's
only been on like a month right so so
and then I think last Tuesday they ran
the pilot and then the episode with the
Spanish episode and then that did wait
what do you mean Spanish episode we did
an episode where mine doesn't speak
Spanish
you wish she goes
that's that means orange
that could be where I come in too
because I speak fluent Spanish but and I
could be like the cousin that makes one
of her yeah but I mean we already we've
done pretty good job of bringing people
in like the ants and all that stuff yeah
and that of just making people part of
the world and you know they're just
introducing them but that's how people
get addicted to the world because they
want to see all the Care it makes them
feel like they're part of it you know
like I miss shows when I really like
them in the end like White Lotus all I
think about is White Lotus right like
you think about also like every
character however small it is it like
adds right to the world I did camel with
the let me see I can't read my thing
and I just found out about it this
morning when I heard her uh I came up
with the girl from Wow Gil really you
missed his appearance really a sidekick
thing to miss with the the girl from
White Lotus oh my God I love her it
doesn't even look like her in this photo
tape it you know she looks good though
right she's so good yeah she's very
funny
she's so good on the show I love her I
love her she seems like she looks like
Good Vibes like nice yeah like her
personality
I know like I know I think I know what's
gonna happen but I'm scared yeah I
watched the trailer I watched the sneak
peek for next week I'm obsessed with the
Italian how many more how many more
there's only one I love the Italian
prostitute girls that's my favorite
story you know I heard that they ought
their friends in real life and they read
for each other during the audition and
the director didn't know but he like
cast both of them that's amazing as like
each other I have Goosebumps oh my God
have you seen my Lotus no oh wait
you must watch it well then he's gonna
watch it for the problem
yeah you know the but the first season's
really good too the one that's White
Lotus oh yeah I will say the thing about
it does take like a episode or two to
get into it because you're like
you're only like what am I investing in
this you know it's very slow build up
but it's worth it
I get recommendation you gotta want it's
a great show but you got to get through
the first episode and then it sucks you
know I'm sitting there and I ain't gonna
pay attention to this [ __ ] that's why I
think it's better to watch Once all the
episodes are out so that you can binge
it I love White Lotus and Wednesday is
another one that's so what am I missing
on Wednesday Wednesday you don't like it
so where am I missing you know what I
like coming of age I like I like high
school story lines and I like like weird
little like freaky I I guess I just love
shows about autism
I like funny stuff no it's it's funny
because well I guess it's not funny it's
like kind of an adventure like mystery
it's like the number one show on Netflix
you know what I like I like because the
world looks I like the way that it looks
yeah
talk about to you and your show like
you're saying like Wednesday's like the
number one show on Netflix and it's like
I feel like and I've never been on the
other side of it but I feel like
networks they choose what shows are
number one right you know they choose
how much marketing budget they're going
to put into a show they choose whether
to put it on the home page so like yeah
Wednesday's number one because it's
shoving it down our throats dude yeah
but I think a lot of people are watching
it too because it's it hits a bunch of
it's a huge it's a child and adult
demographic but what I was going to ask
you with like your show is like you know
how do you feel because like I mean I
don't know about your show but I know
everywhere yeah they did a really good
job of working everywhere I loved to see
that because I know a bunch of friends
like you know hentified on Netflix they
didn't Market that might show that I was
just talking about nothing we had
nothing we had like one billboard
Manhattan Love Story like nobody knew
about it and then
um what was the show Chris Estrada is
doing on how full
uh
it's like on Hulu we got a second season
they got a second season oh that's good
I'm pretty sure I mean I don't know this
my show on hula though hotties there's
not like there's no advertisement for it
I did all my own PR for it I think I
think I don't know for sure and like
Chris DM me if I'm wrong but I feel like
I know like I think Chris might have
done a lot of his own he did he did but
they they pushed it I mean how did they
decide which Hulu what they pick up by
number I think about the feel of it I
think they pick up on their they first
pick up their Originals so ours was done
with a separate production company so it
wasn't in-house production so already we
had odds against us but so far they
haven't picked up any scripted shows
besides the Kardashian
so we're thinking it's not looking good
but I'm trying not to get too sad about
it before it even happens there really
is no way to know what's going to be
successful it doesn't matter if it's
sometimes when I'm bored like we're not
bored but I don't have time to watch My
Friends shows like I have a friend who
just released um a special online uh
he's [ __ ] hilarious he opens for um
Angela a lot oh yeah his name is don't
tell me don't tell me don't tell me Mal
Hall Mal Hall Mal Hall he just released
a special amazing he's so funny based
out of San Diego and I have seen him
live a bunch but I didn't have time to
watch it on YouTube so I just put it in
the back of my browser see this and I
just let it look like the closet oh no
and I'm like that's like could you do
that I got a special place yeah no no I
know yeah you know what I was hurt when
Mount Hall's special came out because I
saw that Angela was like my guy who
opens for me has a special like no none
of my comedian friends posted about my
special like you know what I mean they
all have the rub like it almost feels
like I'm fighting against like my fight
is like what was your special on it's
called it's on YouTube I really
self-released it through helium Helium
Comedy Studios too right 12 specials
it's called jaded
um and it's on YouTube yeah it's good
I'll check it out that's all I watch is
YouTube almost yeah me too I love
YouTube the thing is like that's the
thing I felt like I didn't get the rub
on this one you know the like the and I
almost feel like it's like it makes
people upset like yeah
well I'll tell you the first show we had
to like fight all the way but this one
you know they liked it from the
beginning like the concept of it I think
we stuck to what they wanted and they
were behind it I mean they flew me
Sunday to the football game in Dallas
just to sit there and wave when they put
the camera on me and people went crazy
because that's what I wanted to ask you
so you feel like I feel like I feel like
in since it's only been on a month that
immediately people already know of the
show yeah I shot a PSA for stand up to
cancer and then a guy was working out
there and he goes hey I love you hey
George Lopez I love the show with your
daughter and like that you don't expect
it to come from somebody like that yeah
I mean that's pretty yeah when they're
behind it when everybody it's like you
think that you understand how much
change it would make if there was a team
behind me it's like what's the word that
a lot of like networks use it's like um
their uh and not and their mandate right
oh yeah networks have like mandates
yours fits every box but I think the Gen
Z aspect of the generational trauma old
dad and the and the kids and the
American kid that's right let's just
name the little kid from he's so funny
man he's [ __ ] good man
lip sync to the novella thing that he
didn't speak Spanish you know yes the
the Grandma had him watching novellas
which is of course I'll tell you what in
Spanish and then that [ __ ] kid's he's
good so good yeah see that he's got a
mom momager like that's all I want I
just want one person to bounce off of
like I've had great managers and then it
didn't fit ultimately but like that's
what I'm looking for like a partner in
this like yeah I feel lonely I think I
think they're supposed to be I mean I
mean it's good for sitcoms because it
makes them want three more they want a
two-hour block
of comedies on Friday that you can just
watch Friday like George it's hard to
not have a name and Pitch it even you
know I mean for them to watch your show
on those Friday nights right you know
crazy but also but also if you can
like they're committed to finding three
other companion shows and they want that
block if you if you end up in the block
you could [ __ ] be there for seven
years yeah
yeah that's and like more than two weeks
I'm already I'm in the monthly still but
also it was good to to be able to know
that you're gonna go back and work till
May or that's really exciting yeah to
have like a block of time that you're
not it's like I I've tried this hard to
do Santa for this long and now I just
want a job where I can't do stuff I
think we should talk about doing a show
I'm serious because I didn't do that the
first time because I was just learning
myself and I was sick at that time but
this time you know everybody knows me I
don't have to reintroduce I don't have
to introduce myself to anybody they
already know me yeah and I think it's
easier if you have to put it out there
now and also to gather ideas and then go
in there and Pitch it to them because
you see them every day I see I see
people from the network every day and if
it's a block it can be like another
version version of it yes yeah and like
what the heck was I forgetting but what
was like Whitney Cummings show that only
had two seasons um Whitney it's called
Whitney no it was uh two girls oh Two
Broke Girls two girls
it went it became internationally
syndicated before the first season was
done which is the first show in its
history to do it let's do that but for
eign
I
played like an Italian girl
with an accent and stuff and I got fake
nails for it and then I couldn't take
them off for two months I was like whoa
I feel like you've made it like doing
this for so long that's why I'm younger
than me yeah no but you have ideas
though both of you guys have ideas oh
yeah the Virginia thing I've tried to
pitch and I have a documentary too that
I've been trying to sell for three years
that's beautiful can you guys can we all
meet and prepared okay I would love that
yeah I mean it's just it's just as much
as like going over and said hey man I
got something you guys want to look at
oh let's see it yeah you registered and
you give it to them and then they see it
yeah we gotta get together and then it's
not as hard when you're on the inside as
when you're on the outside
yeah [ __ ] you're on the outside it's
[ __ ] I also feel like naive for even
thinking it could be possible on the
outside because like I feel so far away
from it that I'm like no is it dumb to
me for me to think that it's possible
like I think it's cool I mean I've done
it twice and I think it's virtually
impossible I mean I hate to say it but
everything has to [ __ ] check right I
mean if it was just me doing the show I
don't think I would they would have
bought it but with my end and being my
daughter and then us I mean it's just
it's like the first show was my life
yeah yeah it's a dynamic of we didn't
talk yeah and then now you know we're
talking again and then the show is about
that yeah and it's almost like a
follow-up to like even though it's not
at all a follow-up to your last show it
like it is years later people are
comfortable with you you have a built-in
audience right but I love that Dynamic
though because a lot of people don't get
to see what it's like to be a first
generation American right that's right
that thing of like Hey we're not like my
parents but our parents are still my
parents and I still have to interact
with them and also the fact that like
she like is like married to a white guy
and like she still has a right to her
culture right and they're not married
but she's not there they don't think
that right and even even I know and even
the mom is like uh mom
um you're going away you can't babysit
well maybe if you guys you know
committed to each
I said I want it to look like I had no
place to go but up all [ __ ] crazy ass
hair yeah [ __ ] big ass goatee and
same buttoned up [ __ ] cholo [ __ ] I
love that you know like even somebody
said I haven't really seen the show I
saw the I saw some some footage of it
from far away but his top button is
button and the way he has a button I go
I think that show's funny just because
of the way that wow it's always going to
be buttoned up yeah yeah I like that and
over style yeah that's the yeah it's
interesting what people relate they want
to see things that they can relate to
you want to feel like they're included I
think the one
thing that like the reason it's been so
hard for Latinos to break in is because
we are like diverse within you know what
I mean like we have and like when I
watch like a lot of like Mindy Kaling
shows with this primarily like Southeast
Asians like Indian folks I relate to
those shows still even though I'm not
Indian I relate to them on an immigrant
capacity and I think what we've done
wrong is not using like our Latino
immigrant culture to relate to other
immigrants but what your shoes do show
is doing really well is that like it's
relating to everyone well it's
americanizing the experience the whole
wide range yeah I think that you know um
fathers and daughters dads that don't
get it you know we did think about
anxiety and they're not speaking Spanish
and then the first the the pilot was
about
um wanting to stay with her like you
know through the pandemic lost your
business and all that stuff but then we
do it's just so relatable it's yeah
related I think the time is right for it
but also if that one hits
like Abbott Elementary like I don't know
what's around it you know but it's when
you that's how you build those memorable
blocks of TV that people just [ __ ]
put it on yeah like Friday at eight no
nobody was watching Friday at eight and
now
this show got eyes on Friday at 8 but
also when it's streaming it it gets
three times like we I think we had like
1.7 million and then in a month eight
million people have seen the pilot
that's crazy so it grows at the place
I always have TV anymore like I feel
like when when a show is so good you
don't even want to wait until the day
after it's streaming you want to watch
it the second it comes out and then the
holidays like Thanksgiving you know
people be watching it Thanksgiving on
Christmas or what's the other one and it
is coming back full circle because like
I mean I was on Netflix the other day
and I was like oh I don't know what to
watch and then they that's overwhelming
they have that button that's like let us
suggest something mix it up and then I
go because it feels like you're on TV
changing the channels right they're
trying to recreate that experience so
I'm like we're just going back to Cable
right mine is where like you put on NBC
and you're like
I get overwhelmed I'm like I'm just
gonna smoke weed and listen to the radio
like it's just too much like I just
can't but that's why TV is good it's
like because like you turn on the TV and
you're like but it's rare that I'm gonna
turn on the TV and be like what's on
like I'm going on to watch something
what attracts what attracts you guys to
a show like White Lotus like I don't I'd
be interested to see what you think of
it getting the sound the music
from the first season yeah yeah it's so
addicting um I'll well I also know I
thought the writer is just like an
incredible guy Mike it's not
overwhelmingly
um exciting I think the words well
written
I like the tension yeah I like the
tension but also I knew that when he
wrote it they were like we need an idea
to be shot somewhere where it's just one
place and that's how the idea became a
pandemic it was during the pandemic and
so there was like we have this like
hotel or is it in a hotel or is it in a
whatever nobody there yeah there's
nobody there so they did it in this
Resort and that's how the whole thing
even the girls were saying I told Jimmy
that yeah because it must have been
amazing they're filming Sicily and she's
like well it was in the off season and
there's [ __ ] nobody there yeah and
it's hot as [ __ ] and you have to look
like you're not sweating and and there's
nobody in town so yeah and it's all
working nobody knows yeah I did a short
film the other day I was like oh I
forgot how much you sit around and like
do small talk with like the sound guy
you know what I mean that's the thing
that I feel like is so crazy about this
industry is that you wait around and you
work so hard for so long to find only
get like a real job that pays you and
then you're supposed to be grateful and
like you are grateful but you're also
like this is work like you're getting
paid because I'm putting in the hours
yeah I want to read let's read let's
read the description of the pilot of
friends yeah because friends they didn't
have a job yeah none of them worked no
they were they worked in like the coffee
shop but they had this great apartment
in New York oh yeah by the way you know
what's even better you should read you
know my acting teacher sent us the
review the very first reviews from
friends and one was like Joey is a
misogynist nobody's gonna like these
people it's unrelatable the girls are
too hot the apartment's too big well it
was a call I watched the during the
pandemic and it was extremely important
I watched the documentary on friends
yeah me too I like that and it was like
apparently all in the casting right yeah
and what did you look at us what does it
say I know it's all well it's about
their it's about their chemistry it was
just a magic thing I'm gonna look it up
is that what it's about yeah uh okay
friends yeah the reviews are interesting
what is it called what is it called like
when it's like the short description um
the pilot no it's like the log line
synopsis yeah friends
well when I know the word in a group you
guys that's not good but
let's see what it says
90s comedy TV show based in Manhattan
six friends who go through just about
every life experience imaginable
together love marriage divorce children
heartbreak fights new jobs
and job losses what the [ __ ] but that's
that's literally the most they just not
non-identified
chemistry six young people from New York
City on their own struggling to survive
in the real world find companionship
comfort and support they get from each
other to be the perfect antidote to the
pressures of Life they'll be there for
you yes and the song yeah and the
fountain and the font I mean it all came
together with different colors and and I
love all the like gossip about it like
how Rachel had that haircut everybody
wanted and then her hair stylist
admitted that he was like severely
addicted to drugs and was [ __ ] up when
he cut it
everyone's like I need that little
mullet yeah yeah it's but you know what
there's it's timing it's what's
happening in the world it's the exec
there it's there's so many multiple
things I have to align for something to
work so like I believe that incredible
that it's happened for you again I think
it could I think there could be
companions in there because
there's not a a young
show per se uh about young people
primarily like you didn't see their
parents they had to fly into New York
like they weren't just around yeah one
where the parents aren't around and
you're on your own yeah you don't you
can't run home to your mom and you can't
do your [ __ ] paperwork and also like
I mean if Bad Bunny has shown us
anything is that there's more guys
should take fingers in their butt wait
what was your National audience is he
bad or what he
he's bi but he doesn't like talking I
heard in the meet and greet you could
[ __ ] give him
that's a favorite I haven't gotten I
haven't gotten show me number one did
you guys did you guys see Money Train no
no no the bad pit so bad so bad Bunny's
in the getting a Money Train I gotta
watch it okay
and
you know I'm in Blue Beetle you know I
don't wanna I wanna brag so James Gunn
took over Blue Beetle
uh from came over from Marvel yeah and
he his first public comment
was this because I said welcome to the
boat ship captain
oh that's so cool
I'll wait till people see how
burning this George and he's been saying
that because he just took over DC that's
incredible once you become a DC person
that's that's that's next level one and
you know what I said I said in January
there's the there's the Blue Beetle
poster wow I bang the [ __ ] out of this
on the table because it lights up when
the kid touches it
uh but that that
shit's crazy you know what it is it's
Nostalgia too I think that's another
thing that people want to evoke because
nostalges just a thing right like in
Wednesday when what's her name Christina
Ricci comes back you feel this I feel
like almost emotional and I think it's
that feeling of when you were a child
and you believed in this world is she
playing no she's playing a teacher in
the movie and I think she's gonna have
something to do with the story like the
major storyline later but but
but I think if you watch it like
but you see there well that's why he's
not a good actor I I don't say nothing
but he but he's being chased but also as
and this is the crazy thing like as
charismatic and as incredible as he is
on stage the camera has to has to read
something yeah and it didn't read it he
he didn't he
he couldn't get through to the yeah to
the other side where I mean he played he
didn't really even talk he was chasing
Brad Pitt but you didn't feel nobody
watches that with the sound on it that's
like Harry Styles in that other movie oh
I want to see that Hello darling hello
like okay don't worry darling darling
like everyone's like oh Harry Styles and
it's like it's that same thing yeah he
can act but it's not it's not the camera
is I love everybody but also you have to
internally be thinking I'm chasing this
[ __ ] and if I catch him I'm
gonna kill him instead of I gotta run
over there and not and not seeing it
yeah because if you
if you have to think of it and not just
be like okay
give me a couple seconds but you have to
internalize it and I think he's just you
can't it's not connected yeah yeah I
agree it's great to go to college but
the fact that he was in that movie is
why I was like I was like I need to see
him on this tour because I think he's
now going to start focusing on acting I
don't think he's going to go on tour for
like another three I wanted to see that
show so bad I was so upset is it over
raised it's done yeah
also you know what's really funny I saw
it in LA and obviously like La is like
one of his biggest audiences
no he just sent me the tickets so I went
with friends which is why I was like
that's so hot those tickets are like
[ __ ] three they were two thousand
dollar tickets and I and you didn't even
blow them wow if I give you two
thousands
who's back in your house no I don't
bother yeah yeah that's right you gotta
paint the outside like so I went to the
show and on the way in the Uber the
driver was like oh yeah like you know
how like I mean Latinos like run Los
Angeles you know what I mean like you
run like everything and they were like
yeah people have been sneaking people
into the sofa oh I wish I did it
before 200 a pop cause like everyone who
works at Sofi Stadium
like they're picking up [ __ ] and so then
only a linatino show yeah
I work here bro and then during like a
couple of the songs I remember the area
I was in it just got like a little more
packed you know and they just like the
bathroom attendees are like yeah that's
pretty amazing though it's not easy
tickets for a friend yeah but okay so he
works at an agency and he knew someone
who worked at Sofi stadium so he got
them he's an investigative cop okay he
got that release to me for 300 but they
were two thousand dollar value well you
think there's people that
like could just drive by your house and
see you fingering yourself and then
they're happy they're satisfied
by at noon and you're out there like
rubbing your nipples the guy's like huh
all right I'm good oh for the ticket
yeah oh like if they're first trade no I
think some guys fetish but they don't
ask for anything in return is like the
power in their head knowing that they
like have oh that's another thing see
you know but you know how we would do it
like you know just you know put your ass
up against something and then they're
like they're like here are the tickets
let me drive by you kick me on the Dick
we're good to go you can have the
tickets okay well I think you know
everybody's got a weird [ __ ] thing
yeah I mean I wouldn't have done it this
is the thing I knew he didn't expect
anything from me which is like why I
took the tickets you can't testify the
operation to his mind but yes I can
because then we got drinks and I was
very flirty and he was like not into it
hmm he's like not if bad Bunny's not my
version of very flirty is like hey she's
touching his ears
my version of very flirty is like how
are you doing when I did her podcast I
hit on her the whole time
yeah and then she just was like stop
stop stop but are you you swing too
that's oh that's what we call it
swinging you swing no I'm not pan sector
I'm not what is it what am I where did
you become pan I think you know what I
think it's lazy I'm not Paulie I'm not I
am lazy I just want to make a decision I
like it all you can have it all I like
it all here's the thing about me I'm not
like pan and that I like everything I'm
very very picky I just don't care what
gender you are me too I don't care about
gender very very picky I just don't care
about Jen I'll make it work gender or
general yeah
yeah gender or what was it general in
general General
gender or generals no but there is an
interesting thing with the show that's
gay that is explores immigrancy and
gayness because there's not anything
we're looking that was a few years ago
oh I didn't see that wait that sounds
yeah no but you know I think Aaron knows
everything like love the show love
Victor I love that show
so I have another joke about what the
[ __ ] is love Victor it's a little kid
it's a it's about a children's show
children
boy he's in high school and he's gay and
his parents are very Latino his parents
are not Latino Catholic homophobic at
first at first but then they he comes
out to them and they like learn to love
they come around I showed it it's funny
because I like my dad watched for the
show because I like was watching it at
home and he watched it with me and not
to be like gay but it was this situation
where like my dad watched the show and
he really did learn how to like have to
say the right things because like last
year this girl broke up with me and I
was like really sad and I wasn't talking
to my parents because I didn't want to
talk to them about it because I knew
that they were like a little homophobic
and my dad sent me this long text
message that was like Hey I just want to
let you know like I love you no matter
what like you can talk to me about
anything and like even though that
sounds I always call it with my
therapist I thought I call it like a
Disney Channel moment I'm like Ah that's
so like is it true or not I don't think
it's true it like that he would love me
but I don't think it's true you could
say you could talk to me about it
because no I don't wanna yeah I did it I
still didn't talk to him about it but
just the fact that he sent it yeah it
meant everything to me my parents are
like it's a phase I'm almost 40. yeah
like yeah okay yeah but I usually end up
with men so they think it's just like a
fun thing exactly and that's why like I
have a joke that I was like I told my
parents I was bi they didn't believe me
until a girl broke my heart so badly
that I wanted to kill myself and they
were like oh she is gay oh should we go
beat her up you know no it's fine forget
about her she's non-existent did you see
it come do girls see it come in or not
no girls are more manipulative than men
that's the problem
like dudes wake up with a guy break up
with you
it's all news today I'm sitting there
listening to you but like I see the
value of it though I see the value the
TV value of it because I do too it
hasn't it hasn't been on a network I
mean listen Abbott Elementary School is
a successful show it's about a [ __ ]
Elementary School which is great and the
teachers great writers yeah and then
ours is about the Gen Z and the trauma
and the The Divide and trying to get
back because you know you really the
thing from the father is how much time
do I have left and is this relationship
worth saving and it's yes but a lot of
times yeah a lot of times it's no really
sometimes they're like [ __ ] dude if
my dad's listening to this podcast right
now I love you but like it is this thing
where like every time I would be
listening to this because he's a fan all
right
hates gay people loves George yeah
but it's the thing where like I love him
but it is so hard to go home for the
holidays dude because like say I've been
in therapy for he three years but that's
why your show is so relatable you know I
think I think it is I think there's
something to that because I I don't have
that problem at all and I know it'll
shock your
your children yeah I have a 44 year old
son that's gay and it doesn't bother me
that's beautiful at all when Latinos
come out they go I'm gay they say prove
it yeah
my family's been in therapy for two
years now and it's like changed our
entire Dynamic my parents have like
literally they're like we love that
you're going to therapy we will never go
to things they will that's what my dad
used to say something has to come to a
head something has to come to a head I
was never asked to go to therapy therapy
therapy like think about this every 11
years every 11 years your bones regrow
right so my dad technically is a
different person than he used to be
right the stuff that he did to me as a
kid like however I felt about that I
have to let him allow him to be a new
person that's the problem with me is
that like I haven't forgiven and you
might know different things because
they're not even like going to therapy
and my mom's like just like put it
behind you and I'm like I can't because
like you're not even trying you're not
trying to work but even in in therapy I
I wanna this accountability it's never
going to happen it is up to you to go
like yeah but also if they said okay I
know I'm responsible it's not that easy
either yeah like it's not just
it's the it's doing the work I would I
would say like you know you if they say
you you can't teach an old dog new
tricks unless and sometimes they never
do sometimes you know when when you know
you get to be my age and they say oh you
know my mother died and my father died
they never told me they love me but they
did love you but they never told me yeah
it's like yeah but they they did and
they didn't know how to but still
it's worse on the person that's left
behind you know they were their way yeah
yeah that's the thing we have these new
tools now right to communicate like
emotion and stuff like people don't know
and also to know that like your feelings
are valid and you can like feel your
feelings and then like move on from it
you know I think that's why people leave
the room on the holidays and people are
drinking stuff but when you know the
older person leaves the room and they go
[ __ ] it because that's your that's your
daughter [ __ ] you know what [ __ ] her I
don't [ __ ] all this [ __ ] it's all
my fault like first of all maybe it is
but they feel like they're piling on but
really it's [ __ ] it's the reality of
it and everyone else you feel like
they're getting blindsided but and they
have parents too that's right and that's
where it is it comes down it comes down
but the thing is like right becoming an
adult is realizing that your parents try
their best and they were growing too you
know like my dad grew up I grew up in
Brazil like we moved to America they had
nothing my mom didn't they didn't
like file their taxes it's like wow oh
[ __ ] you know what I mean no no they're
smart but I'm saying and like I'm just
starting a business now now and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I have to like file all these
taxes and I literally have like a
college degree from America
and hers doesn't know what to do there
you go I'm super tired so you go to her
house and you knock and you're a chicken
because I've been doing my taxes since I
was like 10. yeah and just because I
wanted to for fun yeah I'm Type B for
sure yeah I'm Type A
yeah but pretty much I'm just saying is
like how hard is it to be like an
immigrant parent it's [ __ ] it's so
hard what was The Odd Couple about two
dudes that
you know The Odd Couple you're the uh
The Odd Couple one guy was very
fastidious like well-dressed very clean
and the other guy was a sports writer
cigar and typewriter you know kind of a
slouchy and the other guy gets thrown
out and he goes to his house and his
wife threw him out he says can I stay
here and that's [ __ ] the office I
thought that started yeah yeah it's like
that other one where like the the
husband of the two women are gay oh um
the uh with Lily Colin that one yeah and
oh my God a huge show Lily yeah it's
about their Emily in Paris I love that
show
Grace Grace Frankie and Grace Frankie
and Grace Lily tomlin's the oh yeah yeah
the most in the world yeah we just need
like a little we have the premise we
have the premise we just got started on
your show so no I said let's do it I
mean we gotta be a character first we
gotta be a character on TV no I know but
yeah and then we'll show you our little
like pitch deck but let's start to
prepare it though yeah that's what I'm
saying no I'm game get the deck together
because because we got picked up I gotta
I don't know if you heard I have a
lawyer yes no I know yeah but I mean we
did this we put this thing together
from
February
to the Pilot We shot in April and then
we and we went and did the road over the
summer so did you pitch it already with
a pilot written or did you pitch it with
a log line with a log line wow wow wow
and then they paid for you to pick right
the price that's what I've heard is like
what's happening now like yeah but
unless you're not a name and then they
want to see them but also you'll be in
there like I'm bringing something I want
to hear that like I want to produce what
you're that I didn't do that oh George
well we're going to be auditioning
people okay yes I didn't I didn't do
that you know when you're ready no we're
not you're it no that's it no that's it
though that you that's you guys I'm not
kidding I'm kidding no guess what show
you're wearing on the pilot
this shirt that one really you're gonna
let her wear those thick ass corduroy
high up [ __ ] that's your [ __ ] right
there that's it go ahead all right
thanks you guys thanks for coming in
ladies are we done you're done it's been
like two hours
how fast did that go that flew by Gil
hated it he said that's the show we're
gonna see you on
life actually I'm going to text you if
it's not about life
but that's what you're wearing those
corduroy pants yeah I like those pants I
have been wearing these they're like my
adult version of sweatpants I love them
that's what you that's what you're gonna
wear we better [ __ ] get used to it
with no belt yeah super high should I be
wearing a belt yeah like that no okay
this this is I think that's it right
yeah
I totally think that that's it yeah
we're manifesting right manifesting and
you guys are from someplace else yeah
that's real for sure it's so real what
did we say I think we set it up you have
to set it in Virginia it doesn't matter
where it is it doesn't matter Virginia
also opens it up to so many characters
in Virginia too like because there are
the allies of the immigrants right the
friends that we made like along the way
and then there's the people who are like
what well I expected you to swing from
Vine Divine and you're like well we
expected you to have more trees yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's specific I
always say Virginia is like at least
Northern Virginia that's nicer than
where I'm from it's like diverse but
every minority is whitewashed it's true
it's like every minority this guy from
Ethiopia and he's like hello yeah yeah
like they wear like Patagonia vests
everybody wears Patagonia everybody
horseback rides in Charlottesville you
know Charlottesville take a version but
also they did gay marriage too what what
do you mean they were legalized yeah
marriage oh stuff is going on right now
with gay marriage it's crazy this woman
is fighting that she she doesn't want to
do websites that it like for gay people
oh and there's they're trying to rule it
that it's a creative pilot yeah yeah
Pilots free tomorrow
pilot no we're gonna get it she doesn't
want to do a website for two gay people
that are getting married
you don't even know them but you're over
here so then but then are we mad about
it and we fight about oh you want to how
do you feel about it I thought our
Dynamic would be that we were a couple
but you don't think that no I don't
think so you think we're just friends
yeah I think I think it's how you guys
are right now you have a boyfriend but
Japan yeah but then what's our what's
our see my my trouble is always like
what do they do if they're because my
people are always happy Comics we work
in a flower shop yeah I have a lot of
flower shop premises because my parents
yeah we work where they buy where your
parents bought where they where they got
the flowers yeah and then you deal with
the different people coming well there's
also the flower thing is like a lot of
florists have in like Texas have been
denying selling flowers right to gay
people yeah
pilot yeah
all right and then maybe there's
flashbacks to when we first moved there
and we were really immigranty absolutely
absolutely because I have all that stuff
with my ESL teacher being Russian yes
and all this stuff that's right all the
memories of like somebody smelling me
when I first walked into school that's
crazy pilots and then they're like yeah
meaty you know it opens it opens with
somebody smelling you yeah like a little
kid being all nervous POV over there is
coming in yeah all the kids staring at
us
yeah this girl Brandi Watson I remember
her name she was wearing a peach off the
shoulder dress [ __ ] smelled her and
she went like this my thing was like at
least eight years old I learned to tell
like white Americans like when they were
like oh you're Colombian like are your
parents drug lords I would literally my
go-to line was just like I mean Colombia
might make the cocaine but your people
consume it I was eight you're already
defending yourself yeah there you are
yeah all the traumas and stuff comes
there you are yeah what defines it
somebody's smelling you and somebody's
saying that and now you build from the
from that yeah what was the definition
of your childhood that's one they smell
you and that one yeah and then we pop in
and try and uh convince Mayan to yeah of
course yeah but by the way but that one
though yeah I like that yeah I wrote it
down let's let's wrap it up